and one thing people forget when you're
up in exchange you have two rooks
against one one incredibly effective
method
of um it's like the presidential convoy
you know protection the secret service
rides in the back and rides in the front
and that's what you do with your two
rooks you put one in front of the pawn
and one behind the pawn which
essentially guarantees full passage for
the rook so rook c4 is
not the only move and you could play
rook e4 with tempo
but i want to show this concept
[Music]
okay e4
we continue with e5 oops sorry for the
board
all right knight f3 knight c6
let's see what he plays
this should be five okay so
let's play the main line i you know
there's many really uh jessica thanks
for the gift there's the schliemann and
stuff
but we're not there yet
so let's go asics
this is sometimes called the morphe
variation because i think morphe was
actually the first to to play this move
and talk about it after bishop a4 we
we go from the main line which is knight
f6
now here knight takes e4 is possible
contrary to what a lot of people think
people think this pawn is poison it is
not knight takes e4 is a legitimate line
called the open variation and is in fact
incredibly popular at the highest level
but
we continue down
the main path and that is bishop e7
and here white's main move is rookie one
but there's multiple alternatives okay
so now we go b5 and people want me to
play the marshall i will accept those
demands
after b5 bishop b3
main move is d6
um and then white play c3 castles hp
i'll talk a little bit about this after
the game
but the point of the marshall is that we
begin by castling we don't push the
d-pawn just yet
the point is that after white plays c3
we play the immediate d5 sacrificing
upon 85 i think i have played the
marshall once
in a speed run game my first speeder but
the guy plays an anti-marshal impressive
that he knows it a4 is
what's considered i think the most
dangerous line these days it takes a lot
of the sting out of the marshall and
it's an annoying move it's what all the
top guys play
of course the point is that a takes b5
is now a threat this was featured in
magnus against nepo black has three
possible ways to defend against this b4
which we're going to play
rook b8 getting the rook out of the file
and bishop b7 the enchanting the bishop
so
well
let's go b4 let's play with sort of the
most direct move which is just to push
the pawn forward
and here white plays d4
that's the the point is that white
issues c3
it turns out as people have discovered
that white doesn't even need to play c3
because taking on d4 is not not a good
idea it allows white to push that pawn
down to e5
uh we have to defend the pawn on e5 by
playing the move pawn to d6
and
a lot of people here take on e5 i
believe that's the main continuation
there's also a5 yeah he takes on e5
yeah this guy knows theory
and man he's testing me because i will
be honestly guys i don't remember if
you're supposed to take with the knight
of the pun i think you're supposed to
take with the knight here yeah i think
you're supposed to take with the knight
the basic reason is that after taking
with the pawn this construction is a
little vulnerable
because the knight on c6 is no longer
protected by a pawn
yeah this is theory
okay takes the aid and yeah this is a a
popular end game which i honestly have
no idea how to play of course we take
with the rook this is where my theory
theoretical knowledge ends because i
don't play the marshall
so i'm not not a specialist so we'll
figure it out we'll figure it out
hopefully
all right
so
let's think
all right now
i feel like white wants to deploy this
knight to c4
uh why wants to deploy this knight to c4
um
and that's a pretty annoying idea
that's a that's a pretty annoying idea i
am remembering something here
i am remembering something
which is that well what can we do about
it we can't stop knight c4 bishop e6
allows him to [ __ ] our pawns what we
can do is we can try to discourage
knight c4 by pressuring
the e4 pawn on that bishop b7 okay
instantly
all right he plays knight c4 anyway of
course the point is bishop takes c4
knight takes c5 but in that position if
i remember correctly white uh black can
disarm this bishop by playing what move
by playing white move
of course this is hanging
chris velos i still think this is theory
so nothing nothing suspicious yet um
what should we do guys
bishop d5 yeah we have to drop the
bishop back to d5
and contest the bishop on b3
well i mean plenty of 1200's no theory
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that imagine if you studied the line
um
you know just by by coincidence and then
you played it and was people were
accusing of junior how would you feel
about that
um yeah usually 1200s don't know this
but that doesn't mean that if he knows
this we have to hold it against him
that's ridiculous
um
it's unusual and i have my eyes open but
there's nothing
um damning yet
okay so which way do we take guys
yeah of course rook takes knight takes
runs into the very nasty knight c6 we
have to take with the rook
to prevent that and if knight c6 here
then bishop f8
so i'm still
60 sure that this is theory
the end game is supposed to be slightly
better for white but people like magnus
know how to make a draw here
um and that's a lot of grandmaster level
for you right it's like you get a
positions where yeah objectively you're
a tiny bit worse because our pawn
structure is definitely inferior we've
got more weak squares
but our position nonetheless is quite
solid bishop f4 okay that makes sense
so again we can't play rook d8 because
of knight c6
so i propose a move that at least
temporarily freezes the knight on e5 and
gets the bishop out of the
um purview of the rook
i i think bishop d6 is a very natural
continuation here
this makes a lot of sense to me
and of course uh
knight d3 runs into rook takes d3 so
he goes g3 to defend the bishop
but that seems like a blunder to me
if i'm not mistaken
that seems like a blunder
huh
that would be great if i'm playing one
if i'm playing flutter if i'm playing
magnus now anytime you have this
construction that's a very dangerous
situation if anytime you have a minor
piece that's not protected by any pawns
and is pressured by two different pieces
um
you have to
you know your tactical alarm bells have
to go off and if the bishop on f4 can be
distracted that knight's gonna be lost
and you can do that by playing g5
now white is not entirely lost if bishop
takes g5 bishop takes c5
y does have rook takes c5 and limit
limits the losses to in exchange for a
pawn but an exchange in the end game is
incredibly dangerous so
this is definitely a mistake
this is definitely a mistake let's see
if he spots rook takes c5
magnus
does blunders that's right the game is
very far from over i think if white
plays the ensuing end game well it's
going to be
uh quite difficult for us to convert but
this is a good start
yeah rook takes c5 is
the only move otherwise whites down a
piece f4 is
not effective the bishop has plenty of
squares along the long diagonal where it
can protect the wreck he plays it
okay
now an important decision where to put
the rook and we're starting to get into
the level where these relatively minor
decisions really start to add up right
and you don't just want to ignore the
subtlety of it
now first observation we are under no
threat of getting checkmated why because
we have a rook on aaa that is
essentially permanently guarding uh the
back rank against mates which means that
we don't have to bring the rook back to
ea we can use this rook and activate it
we can move it forward and we can use
the other rook in a semi-defensive
posture if that makes sense rookie two
is quite natural
and then the other rook we can bring to
e8 potentially preparing a trade of
rooks
okay c3 is
um that's a dicey move
now blender is a pawn i believe
yeah that wonders upon
of course not bc but rook takes me soon
cb rook takes before still not over he's
got very active bishop so we'll have to
be precise
but now we have a passer and that's a a
huge deal when you're up in exchange
because ultimately white shouldn't be
able to stop it with the material he has
bishop b7 is
sort of a paper tiger kind of move it's
not dangerous
um
generally our our strategy here is to
push the c pawn
and one thing people forget when you're
up in exchange you have two rooks
against one one incredibly effective
method
of um it's like the presidential convoy
you know protection the secret service
rides in the back and rides in the front
and that's what you do with your two
rooks you put one in front of the pawn
and one behind the pawn which
essentially guarantees full passage for
the rook so rook c4 is
not the only move and you could play
rook e4 with tempo
but i want to show this concept
i mean trading rocks would be the ideal
scenario but it's it is hard to force
the trade of rooks and you shouldn't be
this is a common mistake actually when
people start to
devote all of their resources to trying
to orchestrate one particular trade and
if you waste too many moves your
opponent's going to improve his position
it's hard to to force the trade of rooks
here unless you can give a check somehow
of course it's desirable i mean rook
against bishop is just easily winning
because the bishop will be totally
powerless to stop c5
and in general when you're up in
exchange most of the time trading one
additional pair of rooks favors the side
that has the rook
with
you know exceptions of course but the
reason is that neither the knight or nor
the bishop are sufficiently long range
of a piece
they cannot move side to side quite as
easily as the rook and the rook can
start mowing down all these weak pawns
particularly if you have a bishop pawns
that are on the other collar square
okay king f1
now rook c8 is unnecessary
we can begin by pushing the pawn and
rook c8 is not going anywhere
furthermore this is a bit of a trap if
he continues along this path he's going
to lose the bishop of the e4 check
yeah 1600 blitz probably he is
underrated or provisional rapid that
would make a lot of sense
yeah and the anti-marshal
has been played three times at the
highest level in the world championship
so
[Music]
okay bishop f6
yeah and uh how should we proceed folks
yeah either rook c8 or
rook c2 very good i like rook c2 rook c2
is a nice move
it puts the rook on an ideal square
paves the way for the pawn to reach c3
and again roxy ain't no rush
you know if white's rook was on v6 for
example then yes we would want to go
rook c8 because he would be threatening
to put the rook behind the pawn
but as long as there is no rush we just
proceed along with
along our plan
next two moves c4 c3
even if rook b1 we can play c4 wait
until the last possible moment
okay so again we make sure that there's
no mate here
there's no mate
after c4 the rook can swing to d4 but
even if the rook gets to g4 that is
totally innocuous we just go king f8
there's almost never an actual danger to
get mated here
uh in such situations he just doesn't
have enough pieces okay so c3 would be
an extremely instructive mistake c3
would be
a very typical mistake would allow the
rook to get behind the pawn
and this is the
perfect time for us to go rook c8
okay does that make sense
he's yeah check king f8 rook h4 here is
probably the nicest the best uh most
resilient move
and when you're up in exchange and
you're trying to push a passer there
comes a time most of the time when your
opponent
tries to distract you by going for some
of your other pawns
and you have to make the judgment call
of when you essentially start giving
away pawns because you judge that your
passer is unstoppable and generally that
moment arrives sometime when your pawn
is on the third rank which it is here
we also have to determine that if rook
h4 c3 rook takes h7
that may seem very concerning because
there is a made threat there but we can
defend against it very nicely okay he
doesn't play it but before we move on
with the game who can tell me if white's
rook is on age seven here how can black
defend against the maid threat
king e8 very good king e8 rookie
chaitrick and the king walks out to d7
bishop g7 allows our king
to move toward the center where it's
entirely out of danger
so
king aching g7 whatever king d7 king d6
uh the only very tiny point i have to
make is king d7 maybe allows bishop f6
preparing rookie seven with check
although even that is totally innocuous
because our pawn will be already on c3
so yeah it really doesn't matter and
yeah generally i want to put the king on
the opposite square of the bishop so
that there are no
sudden bishop checks
but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
in fact in a classical game i would go
king d6 or d4 checking c5 and just get
the king as active as possible maybe
even get it to b4 and take the pawn on
a4
so
a rule of thumb that i said is that you
want to keep the rooks on
different color than the opponent's
bishop but that's not a
you know that's not a law if you can
ensure that you're not blundering forks
uh then you're more than welcome to keep
your rooks on the same color square it
just marginally increases the risk of a
blunder but risk of a blunder is not an
actual reason not to play a move
like if you can't play with the
understanding that you're gonna blunder
okay rook f4 is a good move i mean very
resilient defense
so we have a choice here right we can go
king e6 or we can judge that yeah
you know we can give up essentially all
our pawns and still be winning
and i think that
that moment has
probably arrived the only issue is that
if we give up all three of these pawns
and then he gives up his bishop for our
other pawn he's going to have four pawns
uh four passers for the rook which is
you know not the most elementary of the
wins but i still think that it's it's
worth going for it i just feel
intuitively that
we're probably going to keep our h pawn
alive that's what we're going to try to
do
now where should we go with our king
yeah we should go
and i'll show i didn't like king e6
afterwards
so we have two options we can go king c6
that's actually quite a smart move
with the idea of rook f6 check king b7
preserving the a pawn or
we can go king e6 or f6 check king e7
rook takes a6
and then we move the rook away and
promote our pawn
and it probably is going to transpire
that he's not going to have time to win
the h1 so let's go king e6 that's more
forcing and now king back to e7
now uh several options we can give him a
check and then go c2
but
if you want to be nitpicky i like rook
a2 here
why because after rook a2 although it is
a little bit slower he's not stopping
the pawn anywhere we don't need to play
fast here it's not a race i mean it is
but after rook a2 there's no going to be
no way to stop c2 c1
and at the end of the line we're going
to have a rook on the second rank that's
incredibly valuable because then we can
later bring our other rook to the second
rank does that make sense
we essentially ensure that once he gives
up his rook for the pawn
um okay king i guess king f7
and that's going to be inevitable
or rook is going to be poised to combine
with the other rook and hunt after his
kingside pawns
yeah of course he can sack the bishop
but then we're up a rook
and we'll probably cling to the h pawn
as well just to make it a little bit
easier yeah he does do that
now the interesting thing is we don't
need to we can go king e6 here and after
rook takes h7
we can go rook f3 and we start mopping
up all those pawns
in fact i like that approach because the
king gets centralized we really don't
need to if you calculate you'll see that
rook h7 is no longer
dangerous rook f3 rook c2 also of course
possible but our rook's gonna get to the
second rank anyway it's over if he tries
to run with this king king g2 rook takes
f2 king h3 he drops not only the h1 but
also the rook the power of two rooks on
the second ring on full display it's
over
well nate the whole reason i gave up the
h pawn and that's the reason i left this
rook on a2 you guys see what i'm saying
if if in this position
you know the rook was on a1 and the king
was on g2 i wouldn't be so so quick to
give up the pawn
but this is over
yeah king ju1 and now
you know the simple the winning method
here is very simple
you just move the rook away as far as
it'll go
and mate is unavoidable notice how the
king dominates the rook
king just totally dominates the rook
and now we zigzag our way toward the
rook
the point is just to stop rook f6 that's
the only way to stave off mate
um
and it's over
that was a very high quality game i
think by our opponent with the exception
of one blunder i think he played very
well but that's just the reality of
chess
g6
yeah i think it was a very high accuracy
game
okay so let's let's start so e4 e5 now
i'm going to go quickly down the opening
i would say that in general in the speed
run you guys are responsible for
educating yourself on opening basics so
for example if you're sitting here
saying i've never seen the ry lopez i
don't know why
he can't do this that's something you
can very easily look up online
um and i don't want to just you know
make this about basic
opening explanations when that exists by
the basinfold but here the point is
queen d4 this is the one thing i will
say
and white black recovers the pawn with
interest because black is white is
forced to lose castling rights
okay so bishop a4 knight f6
castles bishop b7
and by the way this is more accurate
than starting with b5 this is well known
if you start like this then d4 is a very
nasty sideline
so it's better to start with bishop e7
rookie 1 b5 bishop b3 and my main move
is d6 which leads
after c3 castles now the history of this
line is interesting
um in in cappa blanca's day
uh people played d4
but then capoblanca against marshall
actually showed that bishop g4 is very
strong
then people stopped playing d4 for a
very long time and in the last 20 25
years people started playing d4 again
because it was discovered then in fact
this is not the end of the story white
has either d5 here
uh which godikomski really likes to play
that's his pet line or the main move
bishop e3 i take c4 there's
bishop d5 and this is an incredibly
sharp and very interesting line
uh and if you're looking for you know an
interesting sideline in the main line or
lopez this is very much
uh
valid and the reason that rue lopez is
so incredibly hard to play with white
is partially because compared to
openings like the vienna
or the fortnite scotch black has a
ridiculous amount of legitimate
sidelines
and and it's very hard to study
you know daria schweitz recently read a
two volume series on the right lopez
each book is like 300 pages
i mean we're talking about the berlin
the schliemann
all of the a6 lines which are a million
steinitz delayed steinitz the casio
which has become popular recently the
smithslav the archangel the molar all
involved different developments of the
bishop
and and and the open road
books have been written just about this
line
so
yeah knight d4 is even a move which has
to be studied i mean it's it's an insane
amount of theory which is why you study
the wright lopez a lot of it has to be
understanding based you're not going to
remember all of the theory you have to
study the sharp lines specifically
oh there's also the delay statement so
moves like f5 you have to just know but
in terms of these
you know more positional lines a lot of
it is understanding based the briar yeah
so this is not to mention
the fact that this is considered one
could say the main line of the whole rue
lopez
you know the entire opening this is
maybe the tabia and in this position
black has seven or eight valid lines
my main move is knight a5 and c5 this is
called the chagoran variation even
within the chigorin there's
deviations
the briar is knight b8 incredibly
reputable move rerouting the knight to
d7 the zaitsev rook e8 or h6 which
frequently transpose
there is i
sorry there is a bishop b7 of course
there is bishop e6 a rare move that i
played against for russia recently in
the aim chess tournament drew mr wrench
with the sub there is even the move a5
and i've even seen queen d7 played
uh since the 60s and 97
so it's crazy but mainly the breyer and
the jagorn are
the main lines by a country mile closely
followed by maybe not so closely
followed by the zaitsev because i
contradicted myself
and you know
if you want to avoid all of this with
white one way to do that is to play d3
here that this is a far less theoretical
sideline which was incredibly popular
particularly recently
and i was talking about this with my
friend something really interesting has
happened on a broad scale in the last
5-10 years
in terms of top level opening
preferences
which is paradoxically this might sound
ridiculous
until i explain it but there's been a
almost a departure from the most
principled lines if you look at
tournaments in 2005-2006
even toward the end of kasparov's career
around the early 2000s everybody was
playing night orphs people were playing
grunfeld's people were playing literally
the most theoretical lines and you had
these 30 move theory
theory games
um now of course that still happens to a
degree i'm not saying it never happens
but if you look at the opening choices
we have tons of italians the italian is
known as basically the most
non-theoretical
top level opening because of the amount
of different move orders and how
positional it is
you know the berlin end game of course
is theoretical but it's
it's also kind of conceptual based and
tons of people are playing the anti
berlin which is the move d3 so you see
the shift where people are just trying
to get fresh positions that are not even
they're not going for an objective
advantage they're going for positions
that they know better than their
opponent and i think magnus is largely
responsible for that because he
is the originator of this kind of
philosophy or no i'm not necessarily
going for the biggest advantage i'm
going for a position where
you know if you make a mistake you're
going to be much worse so there's
practical pressure and a position which
i analyzed then you didn't
not necessarily the computer's top
choice in every position or the line
that it tries to make
so
just sorry for the uh you know for the
long detour but i feel like that's an
interesting trend and something you can
kind of observe
as you watch super tournaments
and the night orphans
dropped off considerably at the highest
level even though not nobody has refuted
it so the contrary the night of
theoretical standing right now is among
you know the best it ever was
um
and i think it's bled
it's bled to the lower levels you know
there is a trickle-down effect now at
the lower levels you have different
openings so you have the same general
trend where
tons of people are playing the london
right tons and tons and tons tons of
people are playing the italian tons of
people are playing you know d4 based
openings more so than 30 years ago when
everybody was playing king's game but at
the beginning level and the scotch in
these openings less of a trickle-down
effect but still you can kind of observe
that thank you shane kane
and of course danny wrench has
influenced all of it he is responsible
for
chess degrading into what it is right
now
um okay so
back to the game marshall so a4 is the
nc marshall
b4 d4
b4 d6
all right
so
again i can i can talk about the theory
for hours here
but
suffice it to say we're following the
main line yeah so i'm looking at the
opening explorer
and it looks like d takes e5 is um it
looks like d takes e5
is more popular
interestingly i misremembered
here oh yeah and then knight bd2 so for
some reason i was worried about
you know a5 bishop a4 in these positions
but uh
i guess it's not a it's not dangerous
you guys can
explore using the opening explorer
feature
um but taking with the knight is also a
move
okay this is rare only eight games with
queen takes d most people deviate from
the queen trade with queen e2
and ultimately i think white slightly
better
i don't remember how carlson nepo went
if they followed this line or not
i mean ultimately it's just the black as
weaker pawns as i explained and white
has you know the c4 square and the c5
square
if you look at the queen side white has
a positional advantage there so
definitely i would prefer white
the main move is bishop c5 rerouting the
bishop to a better square bishop g5 and
there's the move bishop g4
things get a little bit sharp for
there's two games that went like this
let's see which two games
oh burkitch kachiev and furman clovans
from 1975 both grandmaster games so
very um
you know very uh
very strong line i mean tons of gm games
in this line
okay
so
queen takes the rook takes the a
um knight d2
still follows
some games sorry one sec
yeah so we're still following a bunch of
games bishop b7 is a novelty
most people have played bishop c5 here
with the idea of meeting knights oh
i missed this what is black's idea
i i completely forgot that knight c4
isn't really even a threat here
94 very good
and the point is that bishop f2 is
threatened and this walks into backrank
mate
so
yeah the study plan took me a year to
build that's an interesting feature even
i was not aware of it
that's the real problem it's not that
it's not that the tools don't exist that
most people don't want to use them
so i guess we should be seven is not the
ideal way to stop knight c4 because he
plays it anyway
and well and we get into this
knight takes e5 bishop d5 rook d5
position
yeah and i think so far white has done
everything perfectly
but uh here it's it can get a little bit
dicey because we're threatening knight
h5 and g5 is up is a problem so g3 is
the decisive mistake what do i think
white should have done here
my guess is that there's multiple moves
first of all this is a blunder as i as i
said during the game because if rook
takes d3
but white has to be very careful who can
give me an example of a decent move here
and maybe even bishop f4 is inaccurate
maybe maybe this walks into unnecessary
trouble and white should just like drop
the knight back to c4 or something
but it white is obviously not losing
here yeah so one approach is to go
bishop g3
and this
makes the bishop defend and it does kind
of walk into rook d2 which is a tiny bit
nasty
um
knight c6 doesn't work that's a good try
but after bishop f4 remember the knight
defends the rook here so no
hmm
i would guess rook 81 is a move just go
rook 81
black cannot go knight h5 and if black
well no that's not good if black takes
and goes knight h5
no but this is also very nasty white
actually is losing the game here
g3 g5 wow
so it's somehow not so easy for white to
uh
to disentangle the pieces i i guess
bishop g3 is the best move and after
rook d8 thank you boosted maybe just for
kc1 cold-bloodedly defending then moving
the knight back to chase the rook away
from d2
and it's just interesting how in chess
you get these positions which look
totally innocuous and all of a sudden
things become incredibly dicey just over
one move and this is a product of
undefended pieces anytime you have an
undefended piece like this the 995 is
loose as well it's not undefended but
it's
not well placed you just have to be
incredibly alert to this to these
to these
turnarounds
yeah h3 might also be very good but then
i was worried about rook e8
i think no h3 rook e8 and the knight
cannot be defended and if knight d3 then
still rook takes e3
one true maddie thank you
oh
hot take by danny
okay so g3 g5 in the game is over
um not entirely over but
for all intents and purposes it is i
mentioned that it wasn't so simple
during the game and now that i look at
it with a fresh pair of eyes i feel like
white might have to go like this
and then after we activate the other
rook we're threatening to trade rooks
and we're threatening this
sorry rookie two this is just no bueno
for white
and after c3 rook b2 it really is over
we're just up a full exchange we've got
a passer
and again by using the technique of
putting one rook behind the pawn and one
rook in front of it we ensure a clear
pathway or one
there isn't much to analyze yeah so king
king e2 there's this fork so use tactics
to your favor
rook c8 of course is very important c3
is very sloppy due to rook c4 and i find
beginners to blunder like this very
commonly they think that this type of
position is winning for black but
remember this is the only rook that's
defending the pawn
whoa and wrench with the 10 gifted subs
i just abuse him with my words and and
danny responds by gifting 10 subs
what a mensch
this is a very wholesome moment
toxic streamer
um toxic streamer trash's leader of
company
uh the latter responds with gifted subs
thank you d4nyo for the prime give me
your primes uh-oh we got some one-upping
going on champ with the 20 subs
oh my lance
what is going on today
oh my goodness is this one of those 10
20 30 40 things
all right
relax guys this is crazy
okay
no comment thank you champ for the 20.
it's all about one-upping danny
and kavita one two three with the 10.
oh no no al with the ten i knew with the
ten oh my god
oh my god what is going on kavita and al
simultaneously gifted ten then another
tenth i know
oh my goodness
look what you started danny look what
you started
holy smokes
look what you started
unbelievable that's 40 subs in three
seconds and jason sucks at chess with
the 10.
oh my god
oh my god
this is the ultimate poggers moment
the ultimate foggers moment
this is why i stream thank you so much
folks this is amazing
amazing amazing
yeah we'll see about an encore i was
planning to eat
but
i mean i guess that can wait let me just
finish analyzing i've been so rudely
interrupted by all these gifted subs
so rook c8 here and not fearing thank
you guys much appreciated not fearing
uh rook h4 here
right because we can go c3 or beer mile
with a five oh my god rook takes h7 and
now we just calmly walk out with the
king king e1887
and the last thing i wanted to show
thank you beer mile
is that
okay we give up the pawn here
we give up the other pawn rook a2 is an
important move actually rook c1 in my
opinion is far less accurate
king g2 c2 and this is what i was
talking about
what you end up seeing here is that
white takes the pawn on h7 and even
though you promote to a queen
uh in this version white keeps all four
of the pawns and the win is
far from easy i mean really far from
easy you can park the rook out for and
white starts pushing the pawns i've seen
swindles happen like this of course
black is winning here
but tremendous accuracy is now required
so
accuracy until the end in these end
games is very important so again why
rookie 2 why is this different
although this is slower than going rook
c1
uh it ensures that after we promote the
rook is going to be on a2 it's going to
be poised to pressure the pawn on f2
hopefully you understand the logic here
bishop f6 king f7 he decides on bishop
takes c3 of course probably bishop g5 is
more resilient
but ultimately i mean you can't go here
because of rook a1 so
and rook f6 is a useless check because
of king g7
all right
so
king e6 rook f3 and that's it all of the
pawns fall with checkmate
great game by our opponent i have to say
once again there was just one mistake
and other than that he played a very
very clean game
[Music]
you